angela merkel's farewell visit to the
united states
where she is going to be honored with a
doctorate
from the world renowned johns hopkins
university
while chancellor america is one of the
longest serving world leaders
and will step down after germany's
general election
in september in which she's not running
as a candidate well she began her visit
with a working breakfast
hosted by vice president kamala harris
and is due to meet with
president joe biden momentarily
and those were scenes from the ceremony
that is
getting underway well we have team
coverage for you uh with the william
bluecroft here with me
on the set and our washington borough
chief ines poll
right outside the white house and guys i
just want to preemptively apologize i
might have to interrupt you
should the ceremony get underway in
earnest but want to go to you in the
meantime first
ines events in washington slightly
overshadowed obviously
by the catastrophic flooding taking
place here in germany
i understand the chancellor spoke about
it what did she say
exactly she spoke about it and i just
talked to some sources within
the merkel camp and they said you know
if this would not be
her last visit as chancellor to the
united states it's very well possible
that she would be on her way back to
germany
he she gave her deepest deepest
sympathies
to the families of the victims really
shaken
by this horrible horrible catastrophe
in germany and it is kind of taking away
this
joy of this last visit of hers because
as we know she has a long and deep
connection
to the american presidents
and this should have been a celebration
of the u.s german
the transatlantic relationship but as
you said laila it is overshadowed by the
catastrophe happening in germany right
now
right casting a very dark cloud indeed
in the meantime uh
just a few moments from now chancellor
merkel will receive an honorary
doctorate from johns hopkins and we
expect her uh to also uh
address the audience there make a speech
what do you think she'll say
well she's a scientist right and she got
several doctoral uh honorable doctoral
degrees but she also
owns kind of a real one and
as we hear that really means a lot to
her it's not just a gesture that really
means a lot to this woman who has spent
so much time
in science and some people even say she
might go back
to science after she leaves
the chancellery in germany so it shall
be interesting
to hear i'm sure that she will
address the big topics like fighting
the pandemic she still is a big big
advocate
to be very very careful of spreading uh
the virus that's also something we
experience
here uh we got to test it again before
she comes she's really really careful
when it comes to coping 19. now uh we're
waiting uh we're
also showing in a small screen right
next to you uh live pictures
we're waiting for that uh ceremony to
get underway at the johns hopkins
university where the chancellor will
receive an honorary doctorate
uh ines this is for all intense intents
and purposes and for the purposes of
this conversation probably her
final trip to washington she'll be
meeting with president
joe biden shortly do they know each
other well how would you characterize
their relationship
yeah sure i mean they have met a couple
of times obviously
when joe biden was the vice president
obama they have a very warm relationship
joe biden and his administration can't
stress the fact enough
that germany is one of their biggest
biggest alliance but we also lila
mustn't forget by the end of the day
joe biden as all the other presidents
before him
will take their own country first he
doesn't as
donald trump say america first but he
also
like really tries to bring business back
to the united states
and has a very very different approach
to do
business with china for example than
angela merkel because
he and many americans do so sees
china as a huge huge competitor so it
shall be interesting uh
to listen to the press conference what
we obviously also
follow here on dw news and get a little
bit of a feeling how this meeting
really went but overall it will be again
a celebration of the us
german relationship it will be a
celebration of the u.s german relations
we just saw
in the live pictures the camera zooming
in on
the door but nobody's coming out yet i
want to bring in
a will at this point in the the
conversation
um president biden very much putting
america first
you know maybe not using that that type
of terminology but for all intended
purposes
america first the chancellor has
suggested now also that
europe should put itself first can you
speak to that a little bit more
sure and as enos rightly pointed out
it's the the duty and responsibility of
any
leader of a country to put their country
first and put their country's interests
at first
uh and and many of of of the policies
that donald trump put into place whether
it was tariffs um
especially specifically the the tariffs
that it's handling uh both
to europe and to china are still in
place and that joe biden has in a way
carried that over
saying look to our european allies you
need to
to put up or shut up and and give us a
reason for us to continue
investing in you both in security and
per in personnel
to give voters in the united states a
reason
to continue engaging in the world a
reason to keep reaching out
to uh europe and germany specifically a
reason to keep this transatlantic
relationship going 30 years after the
cold war
ended thus ending the immediate reason
that this whole relationship exists in
the first place and joe biden is saying
you need to give us reasons otherwise my
own
political future might be in danger
domestically here in the united states
and that is how
foreign policy and domestic policy
really come together or at least joe
biden is trying
to bring them together but of course
with a very different tone
very different rhetoric than what we
heard during the trump years
joe biden of course deeply values the
relationship with europe you could see
that in the the people he's picked
for the state department not so many
ambassadors yet
uh across the european union or really
all around the world
um but very much a new tone of how we
can find
not a transactional relationship but a
way that both sides can win
all right i want to go back to ines
standing by right outside
uh the white house on the lawn there um
inis uh
almost 16 years of course at the helm of
germany chancellor angela merkel met i
understand four u.s presidents
which president in your opinion was she
closest to
would be easier to answer whom she was
the furthest away from if one can say so
that obviously was donald trump we all
maybe recall this moment when she was
expecting him
to shake her hand in the oval office and
re she refused it and with a typical
merkel face she gave this little smirky
laugh and like doing that with her
shoulders
she was very very close close with
george w bush that was her first
president why is that
as we know angela merkel grew up in
eastern germany and
president reagan and president h bush
who is the father of president george w
bush really helped bringing down
the wall helped reunify germany and
angela merkel herself said once in an
interview
if it wouldn't be of george h bush i
wouldn't be
where i am and this really close feeling
to the bush family
was transported into her relationship
uh to uh her first president to george w
bush i had the chance to talk with him a
couple of days ago and he also stressed
that fact so i think that is fair to say
with obama they shared really like an
intellectual closeness the beginning was
a little difficult
we might recall that he wanted to
campaign in front of the brandenburg
gate and she refused him to get that
beautiful spot because
she said only presidents are allowed to
speak there
and joe biden she knows him for a long
time and i'm sure it will mean a lot
that
he is her last president and inez
i just want to let you know that the
chancellor
has just gone on the podium and
i think everybody's taking a seat then
and getting ready
for the ceremony to start let's take a
listen
all of walk all of washington welcomes
the chancellor here this morning
including washington's warm weather
i am lou forster chair of the johnson
university
board of trustees and i want to extend a
warm welcome to everyone here this
morning
to my colleagues of the board to
university leadership
to our students and especially to
ambassador haber
and most especially to the delegation
from germany
and our guest of honor chancellor angela
merkel
today is an auspicious day and i am
truly delighted to be
with all of you here at the paul h nitsa
school of advanced
international studies to present
chancellor merkel with our university's
highest recognition
an honorary doctorate of humane letters
the purpose of an honorary degree is to
recognize and celebrate
extraordinary human achievement in a
manner
that aligns with the values commitments
and aspirations of the johns hopkins
university
chancellor merkel joins an illustrious
group of political leaders of germany
becoming the fourth since 1976
to receive this honor
and we will hear more detail in a minute
there are strong
and enduring bridges between our
university and germany
madam chancellor truly we are privileged
to bestow this degree upon you today
thank you again for being here and now
let me turn the podium over to my
excellent colleague
dear friend the 14th president of the
johns hopkins university
ronald j daniels
uh thank you lou good morning all let me
echo lose welcome to allen especially to
our distinguished honoree
chancellor merkel back in march 2020
in the earliest days of the cove at 19
pandemic the world was gripped by
uncertainty
precious little was known about the
virus or the toll that it would take on
our societies
a toll that now has tragically realized
more than
four million lives some leaders however
quickly grasp the gravity of this
looming emergency
and this makes it help not only for
individuals and communities around the
world
but for the future of democracy itself
you chancellor merkel were among them
on march 18th you addressed the german
people
with your trademark frankness and
integrity
whole no doubt by your years as a
research scientist we have to embrace
this as a university
um to say what was known about the virus
what was still unknown
and to acknowledges the sacrifice the
sacrifices this moment would require
for from each of us for the good of all
your decision to make that address was
animated by a core set of principles
as you said then and here i quote from
the english translation
this is part of what open democracy is
about
that we make political decisions
transparent and explain them that we
justify and
communicate our actions as best as we
can
and democracies do this you insisted to
save and improve lives
because in your words no one is
expendable
everyone counts for me this statement
reflects so concisely and movingly
the animating principles of chancellor
merkel's leadership
and of liberal democracy more generally
accountability and transparency
clarity of expression and and trends and
and transparency sorry clarity of
expression and purpose
and a profound care for both individual
and collective life
for more than 15 years angela merkel has
embodied these values as she has guided
her country
and has been a beacon for europe and
indeed the entire world
through multiple global crises with her
singular combination of pragmatism and
idealism
advancing crucial reforms through
compromising collaboration
without ever losing sight of core values
she has been a vocal defender of human
rights for all people
even in the midst of growing nationalism
and isolation
she has worked across national
boundaries to support and buy
other countries in times of distress
where they're helping europe navigate
the great recession of 2008
or addressing the human suffering of
refugees in 2015
and she has been a leader who through
her policy-making
prowess and her presence has advanced
gender equity around the globe
east germany under the shadow under the
dark and harrowing shadow
of the stasi angela merkel witnessed
firsthand the methods by which closed
authoritain societies stifle inquiry
inhibit flourishing and treat citizens
as expendable
her political career has been a stirring
and indeed a
potent rebuke to such modes of
governance
thanks in no small part to her immense
contributions
and to her steady hand she has helped to
ensure that germany
and so many other european nations have
remained open
dynamic societies that place a premium
on freedom of speech and thought
that welcome dissent and heterodoxy that
encourage
the free flow of information ideas and
to support the view
that nobody is expendable and that
everyone counts
in truth i would like to think that
these same principles have guided
our own institution since its founding
it is a central part chancellor of our
origin
story the johns hopkins university took
its inspiration
from the german university model born of
a shared commitment to free
inquiry open debate and the pursuit of
truth through rigorous research
and adapted it to american soil while we
are proud to call ourselves
america's first research university we
have not forgotten
that our nickname used to be gertiang
in baltimore so madam chancellor
we hope you will see your new
association with johns hopkins
as a homecoming of sorts and know that
we recognize you for having
so fully embodied often under the most
strenuous the most challenging of
conditions
the highest ideals of our university and
of the open democratic society
it has so long to serve on behalf then
of the entire university i want to
welcome you officially
to our academic community and of course
i am
thrilled that you have embraced that
membership
uh wholeheartedly offering to speak
today to our students
who are the future leaders and guardians
of the world
you have done so much and in such a
remarkable way to shape
now for the degree presentation i'll
turn things over to our interim dean of
the johns hopkins paul h
nitza school of advanced international
studies kent calder
dean calderon
chancellor merkel you stand before us as
one of the most powerful
leaders but also as a woman of science
dedicated to the pursuit of knowledge
and truth in all human endeavors
your political career began with the
fall of the berlin wall
and the reunification of germany
and for the last three decades you have
been a steadfast force
in bringing young people together
whether by holding europe
together in times of strain or by
addressing climate change
or the and the fate of our planet or
championing international
solutions to the world's most difficult
problems
from humble origins you have risen to
become one of the most
important global leaders of our age
displaying all the while uncommon
strength
conviction and humanity
angela merkel for finding your power and
sharing your vision as a world leader
the johns hopkins university is proud
to confer upon you the degree of doctor
of humane letters
honoris causa
[Applause]
nope
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
well dean calder you may be interim but
you have just accomplished what may have
been one of the more challenging
uh tasks that uh you will confront
during your team
uh thank you so much madam chancellor
this is the official part
uh by virtue of the authority vested in
me by the board of trustees of the johns
hopkins university
i confer upon you the degree doctor of
humane letters together with all the
honors
rights and privileges pertaining thereto
and i'm now going to present you with a
diploma indicating that
this honor has been conferred and um
you have received uh the uh in sign of
the degree from dean calder so i think
we're all official
uh with this final act so let me present
this to you
thank you so much
and if i could invite you to the podium
thank you so much
president ron denis president
of chair of
ladies and gentlemen
thank you very very much for inviting me
to be here today it is a real pleasure
to be here of course
and i feel very honored by the warm
welcome
with which you've received me as well as
the honor that you've conferred on me
it means a great deal to me because
this doctor of humane letters this
honorary doctorate shows the friendship
between our countries
and the particular ties between myself
and the johns
hopkins university as well it is a
unique occasion
in a unique time last year
you had a number of lectures and events
that you could only hold digitally
and most of my appointments as well had
to be held
in a virtual digital manner which is why
i'm all the more pleased that
once again we can meet in person and see
each other face to face
if i think back to my last visit to the
united states in may
2019 it's hard to
imagine what has happened since this
time
two years ago very few people
thought of a virus when they heard the
word corona but since
18 months now we have seen how the world
has been in the grip of this virus and
how it has changed our world as well
and if the pandemic has taught us one
thing it has taught us
how little is certain
even those things we take for granted as
certain
it teaches us that in
everything we do in everything we think
we must prepare for the unexpected
we have learned in the pandemic and are
continuing
to to learn as well as our the
vaccination programs are starting to
show their first effect that we must
remain
alert because the virus is still here
we are combating a rising number of
cases across the
world thousands of people are dying
every
day of covert 19 and we've had more than
4 million dead already on the planet
so these are just numbers but behind
every number
are the fate of an individual people
who had families and friends who grieve
them
families and friends who will never feel
the same as they did before the pandemic
i know that we are all just longing for
this dreadful pandemic to end
because it requires so much of us and it
grinds us down
and of course we want to get back to
normality
but we cannot ease up
the pressure now because the figures
that we are seeing
[Music]
are as worrying as they were on the very
first day of the pandemic we need to
keep up the pressure we must continue to
analyze these
dates and facts and draw the conclusions
that they tell us
all of these facts and figures are ones
like the johns hopkins university
has delivered there's almost no other
name that is so
associated with collecting and
processing the facts and figures of the
covert 19 pandemic
as that of the johns hopkins university
in baltimore usa since january 2020
the coronavirus research center has
provided researchers and politicians
with
data that gives them a tool to track
the development of the pandemic and this
is crucial because it has contributed
to helping us respond to
the pandemic and to ensure that we
strengthen international cooperation as
well because without
joining forces we would never be able to
cope with the pandemic of this kind
and for this excellent work that you
have done
i want to thank you i profited myself
from the facts and figures generated by
the johns hopkins university
but it's hardly surprising that it is
particularly the johns hopkins
university
that has helped the world with this
service in the pandemic because this
university
veritas firstly verity will liberate you
is it slogan and has always aspired
to truth
and its first president daniel german
in 18 76
your founding year devoted the
university
and its researchers to independent
thought and encourage them to share
the findings of their research as well
urging them to think independently if i
may speak on a personal note
was not the environment that i
experienced as a young physicist before
the fall
of the berlin wall in
the laws of physics are determined by
nature not
by some state apparatus and even these
german regime couldn't change anything
on that
but it took all those years
until the fall of the berlin wall
for things to really change the
aspirations of the people in east
germany to
have freedom we're stronger than the
barbed wire
and the berlin wall the peaceful
revolution brought the wall down
on the 9th of november 1989 and this was
the beginning of the end of the east
german regime
and only less than a year later on the
3rd of
october 1990 germany was once again
unified
peacefully and i will never forget the
huge contribution
played by the united states of america
at this time to achieve these changes
and i personally
must say i will always be grateful to
the us for this
germany and the us have very close ties
and these close ties can be seen in the
university landscape as well the core
of the german university system is
bringing together teaching and research
and in the us this is a duality that is
particularly strong at the johns hopkins
university which has invested
in research and development almost more
than any other and it's hardly
surprising
your former president stephen muller
referred to this
of the modern german universities miller
said at the time
he would also have to be seen as the
grandfather of america's universities
not because what he had written was so
influential in america
but because his ideas
were ones that had spread across the
academic
landscape because so many american
scholars who had studied in germany
took these ideas back home with them the
close tie between teaching and
researching
is something that makes it typical
that the one university
or the one faculty the american
institute for contemporary german
studies is
part of your university and this
institute
aims at ensuring that there is an
understanding of potential solutions for
the big
challenges facing us in our age on both
sides of the atlantic
based on our common values pursuing our
common interests
this requires a comprehensive dialogue
naturally across academic communities
and beyond this in the political sphere
as well both bilaterally
and within the framework of the eu
usa dialogue on the occasion
of president biden's trip for example in
june of this year
shows it is significant that the last eu
usa summit came up with some specific
ways of combating the covert 19
pandemic and has fleshed out
the spirit of dialogue by having a trade
council as well as other
bodies in order to strengthen
transatlantic
relations the signal
of closing ranks was also sent out from
the latest
nato summit in brussels joining forces
in a commitment to
the mutual alliance
agreement which shows
our alliance the way forward
dialogue and working together on the
basis of a partnership
assist us when it comes to multilateral
commitment
to pursue our ideas together and to
involve new and old partners into this
aim this is particularly true in our
work in the united nations
because this stands for working together
on the basis of an order on the rule of
law
charters that are universally valid but
ones which we have to say are getting
harder and harder to implement because
of the
blockades that we are seeing again and
again stopping
the u.n doing what it should do so we
have to ensure that the un has a greater
capacity to act
because it has the greatest opportunity
to come up with global responses to
global challenges
connecting in our diversity in our
vulnerable world
means we must join forces and bundle our
strengths
and we see this in noah in a way we
haven't for a long time in the covered
19 pandemic it must be clear that we can
only overcome this pandemic
together and the key is access to
vaccinations
particularly the poor countries of this
world need them and this is why the us
and germany are supporting the global
initiative act accelerator
in combating the pandemic the
g20 global nations but also
particularly the g7 nations have a
key responsibility and so the
commitments of the cornwell g7
summit are of particular importance over
the aim is to have over 2 billion
vaccinations available
by 2022. what's remarkable above and
beyond this
are our agreements to combat climate
change
for the international
support for sustainable global
infrastructures
ladies and gentlemen
americans germans and europeans we are
allies in nato we are partners in
international trade we share common
values and interests
there are no two regions in the world
that have
such common interests and such close
values as europe
and the usa and because this is the case
i understand the great honor that you've
bestowed on me today
as also being an expression of
the close ties of our two countries and
for that
i am truly grateful thank you
now for our international viewers just
uh joining us a
very uh warm welcome to dw news and to
our special live
uh coverage chancellor angela merkel
they're
honored with an honorary doctorate from
the world
renowned johns hopkins university
and we've got team coverage for you
trying to unpack
what just happened william bluecroft
here with me on the set
and in washington getting ready to talk
to us
our very chief enes pole right outside
the white house and she made it just in
time let's go to her
right away ines a great show
of warmth that we just witnessed
absolutely uh wasn't it and i mean just
to begin with the ending she really
stressed the importance again of the
relationship
between europe and the united states
saying that these two countries or these
two parts
europe is not a country as we know are
so important for
each other and there isn't anything else
than europe and the united states
which shares deeper commitment and
values
it was a a celebration of science uh
when the president of john hopkins
introduced her
he stressed the fact that she is a
scientist that she believes in facts
that's not true for every world leader
as we know
and that the university system
in the united states kind of copied the
german
system angela mackle herself was
referring to humboldt as the grandfather
of the idea that teaching and
research has to come together in a
university
so that was a celebration i shall say of
love between germany and the united
states
and a true commitment that science
matters
her handling of the pandemic inez
featuring
very prominently
absolutely i mean angela merkel from the
very beginning i think of
kovit 19 made it really clear that she
takes it seriously
she herself was wearing a mask still
when other leaders kind of
put it down she was one of the first who
really said that this is
a deadly worldwide virus which only can
kind of fault if the world comes
together she also stressed the fact
how important john hopkins university
was in fighting the pandemic because
as we might remember it was john hopkins
in baltimore just out of washington
which delivered all this crucial
information
in the beginning all these figures all
these data
scientists needed but also politicians
needed to really
come to the right conclusions and and
find a way to deal
with the pandemic but laila
just to give you a little bit of a
perspective right outside the white
house here there are protests
protesting against angela merkel because
she is not supporting the patent weaver
which would be
which would enable countries all around
the world to produce their own
vaccination
so this is something where there is a
huge disagreement here in the united
states
with angela merkel and this might come
up later in the press conference
it's such a great segway ines so thank
you so much for that because i was going
to put that question to you
uh william what ines just alluded to
because there was this moment during her
speech where we both kind of held her
breath
is she going to announce of removing the
patents for the vaccines
right i i guess we were hoping beyond
hope something really truly newsworthy
was going to come out of that speech
she just kind of papered over it and
talked focused more on
uh the international consortium through
the un uh to get vaccines
into uh lower income countries which is
we should
note is a very important uh piece of
this puzzle in getting the whole world
vaccinated but it does it is as enos
pointed out one of the many
issues that's dividing the united states
in germany right now which is this
question of patent
waivers of course we should we should
show the other side that
the biden administration has also put
america first by making sure that the
united states had
all of the supplies needed to make the
vaccine and made it very difficult
to get vaccinations out all around the
world so there are many ways to get
vaccines into the arms of
of people all around the world
especially in lower income countries
patent waivers is one way to
possibly do it of course on the european
side they've been criticizing that
saying
yes that's all well and good but there's
a lot of technology transfer that has to
happen here to be able to make very
advanced vaccines
in places all around the world it might
just be faster
just to lift some of the import export
restrictions
in the united states and also the united
kingdom to a certain extent
that would also get vaccines faster all
around the world
so no we didn't hear any quite big
policy changes that we thought
maybe there'll be some resolution uh but
nonetheless
uh angela merkel very concerned uh she
said many times about
about really ending the pandemic
everywhere because it can't be over
anywhere
until that happens and you know as
you're reporting we were showing
pictures
uh on a lighter note of the chancellor
having
some problems with the ceremonial
robe of putting it on one of those
things that have made her of course
throughout her tenure very relatable to
many people enos want to go to you if
i'm a president
joe biden did put germany a little bit
on the spot when it comes to
uh the waivers for vaccines by saying
that he does support it
and then germany had to come out and
basically defend uh
not doing that
yeah it's it's really interesting what
will said and i think he's perfectly
right i mean
we all remember that it took the united
states a long time before they really
exported the vaccination maybe from a
kind of domestic standpoint
understandably so because it was the
beginning of the new biden administer
administration and he really wanted to
be
successful in fighting the pandemic to
really kind of have a good start but
uh some people criticized biden overs
over that saying hey
it's easy to ask germany to allow uh to
export the vaccination but being so
hesitant to really export
the vaccination yourself i think uh will
is right
um uh it it we mustn't jump too short
here
yes maybe it would be a good idea to uh
to open up the patent
to allow the weaver patent patent but we
also have to keep in mind it is
very very difficult to really produce
this vaccination there are shoe
countries
like india which would be able to do so
but there are many many countries which
really need
uh the vaccination and not just the
patent
all right we're going to have to leave
it there team coverage with the
washington borough chief
ines standing on the white house lawn
and with me here on the set
william gluecroft thank you both so much
for your coverage you've been watching
our extended live coverage of the german
chancellor angela merkel
in washington d.c the chancellor just
received an honorary
doctorate from johns hopkins university
she's paying a farewell
visit to the united states it's one of
her last overseas trips
as the german leader later she'll hold
talks with president
joe biden on a range of issues including
climate change
global security and the pandemic
university ronald j daniels
well her farewell trip is overshadowed
by
severe storms that have been taking
place here in germany and that have set
off the worst flooding in decades
at least 42 people have died including
two firefighters who drowned
dozens of others are still missing while
german chancellor angela merkel
who you just saw in washington expressed
her sympathy
for the victims of the flooding take a
listen
i'm shocked by the reports that are
reaching me from the places that are now
completely underwater in which people
have rescued themselves in a situation
of great need onto the roofs of their
houses
and hopefully will also be rescued i
mourn for those who have lost their
lives in this catastrophe
we don't know the number yet but there
will be many
some in the basements of their houses
some as firefighters trying to bring
others to safety
my deepest sympathy goes out to their
families